Traduttore: Massimo Garzotto
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Gli ecosistemi hanno
un'intelligenza acustica.
Per tentare di capirlo, sto conducendo
un progetto di ricerca, a lungo termine,
che indaga l'elemento più rilevante
che in una foresta densa
giunge ai nostri sensi:
il suono.
Ho sempre avuto una specie di ossessione
nel raccogliere i suoni dell'ambiente
sin da quando, da giovanissimo,
nelle campagne e nei boschi
di Urbino, dove sono nato,
passavo letteralmente nottate intere
a registrare, aspettare,
registrare il paesaggio sonoro perfetto.
L'idea era quella di dare
la possibilità ad altri
di fare la stessa esperienza di meraviglia
nell'ascolto dell'ambiente acustico.
Oggi sono un compositore, sound designer,
insegno musica elettroacustica
e studio il mondo sonoro naturale
da circa 15 anni,
da quando ho fatto un'esperienza,
nel febbraio 2002, in Amazzonia,
in un'area dell'Amazzonia centrale,
che confermava gran parte delle intuizioni
[avute] fino a quel momento.
Durante la registrazione
di un "Dusk Chorus",
il coro del crepuscolo,
quel graduale momento di passaggio
che sta tra il giorno e la notte
che è generalmente molto attivo
negli habitat naturali,
ho capito che quell'ordine
ed equilibrio che percepivo
era il risultato tangibile
di tutti i processi dell'ecosistema
istante per istante.
Attraverso i microfoni, molto sensibili,
con cui stavo registrando
ho ascoltato per tre ore consecutive
le vocalizzazioni coordinate
e interdipendenti delle varie specie
che eseguivano una precisa partitura
scritta probabilmente
dall'evoluzione naturale,
dalla selezione naturale, anzi,
di 65 milioni di anni di evoluzione.
Le centinaia di voci di questa polifonia
erano attivate in prima istanza
da luce, temperatura, umidità,
in modo automatico, quasi;
ma ogni individuo emetteva
dei segnali acustici, dei segnali sonori
con una precisa
e specifica funzione vitale:
nulla [era pronunciato] a caso.
E questi segnali entravano
in nicchie sonore
frequenziali e temporali
nell'arco delle 24 ore intere.
Percepivo che quell'orologio
era tuttavia un meccanismo fragilissimo,
tanto più fragile quanto più alta
era la biodiversità del sistema
e dell'habitat in cui
la canoa stava entrando.
In tutto il pianeta, oggi,
quel miracolo di sincronia bioacustica
è in via di estinzione.
(Suoni ambientali)
[Frammenti di estinzione]
[Il suono intelligente
degli ecosistemi, rivelato.]
La registrazione precedente a questo
video, quello che sentivamo in sottofondo,
è stata fatta in Amazzonia nel 2002.
Se oggi andassimo
nello stesso identico luogo,
nella stessa stagione,
nella stessa ora del giorno
e con le stesse tecnologie,
la registrazione probabilmente sarebbe
già più povera e meno organizzata.
Lasciatemi dire qualche dato
sull'estinzione.
Il tasso di estinzione presente
è stato calcolato essere
tra le 100 e le 1000 volte superiore
all'estinzione di fondo, quella naturale.
La IUCN - International Union
for Conservation of Nature,
l'organo deputato,
pubblica dei dati abbastanza sconvolgenti:
un ottavo degli uccelli,
un quarto dei mammiferi
e quasi la metà degli anfibi
delle specie conosciute e monitorate
è entrata nella lista rossa
delle specie in estinzione.
Le previsioni degli anni '90,
che parlavano di 30.000,
di un'ipotesi di 30.000 specie l'anno
ovvero quattro specie ogni ora
che vanno estinte,
si sono rivelate corrette.
È in atto una catastrofe silenziosa,
assolutamente non trattata dai media.
La vita sta globalmente collassando
in quella che viene definita
la sesta estinzione di massa,
che questa volta è provocata
dall'impatto - cosciente, direi -
di una specie, homo sapiens,
sulla biosfera.
Deforestazione, inquinamento
e specie invasive,
come drivers, diciamo dell'estinzione,
ma soprattutto i cambiamenti climatici
che oggi si aggiungono,
stanno modificando gli habitat naturali
e li stanno impoverendo
ad un livello molto ampio e velocizzato.
La situazione è talmente grave
che non c'è tempo di dimostrare,
anche con il suono,
che le cose stanno cambiando,
come spesso mi viene chiesto:
ma stai comparando le registrazioni
tra il passato e il presente?
Non sento questa esigenza,
bensì un'esigenza diversa:
quella di registrare il prima possibile,
e in più luoghi possibili,
frammenti di questo patrimonio
sonoro immateriale.
Il progetto "Fragments of extinction",
già scritto nel 1998,
sta registrando quindi
interi cicli circadiani
di 24 ore di registrazione continua
in habitat molto specifici,
quelli che hanno la più alta biodiversità,
come priorità.
L'area di interesse
è quella intorno all'Equatore:
5 gradi sud e 5 gradi nord.
Sappiamo che all'Equatore
l'incidenza delle stagioni è minima
e la durata di giorno e notte
è uniforme da milioni di anni.
Quindi i ritmi del paesaggio sonoro
sono estremamente regolari, molto belli.
All'interno di quest'area,
la priorità va nelle foreste
che sono primarie
ovvero sono nel loro
stato originario, intatte.
E all'interno di queste aree
la priorità va in foreste
che sono ad oggi indisturbate,
quindi non c'è nessun tipo
di attività umana. Luoghi remoti.
In questi ecosistemi remoti
possiamo davvero ancora rintracciare
la firma acustica dell'evoluzione.
Ma appunto bisogna fare in fretta,
per fissare a beneficio
delle generazioni future
l'impronta acustica
di polifonie primordiali
che si degraderanno velocemente.
Il progetto "Fragments of extintion"
è sempre stato nutrito, diciamo,
dall'essere al crocevia tra varie
discipline di ricerca e approcci:
quello tecnologico,
sulla registrazione 3D del suono;
quindi le tecnologie
più avanzate oggi disponibili;
quello della scienza, l'analisi ecologica
ed eco-acustica dei dati;
l'arte, quindi la creazione,
la realizzazione di sistemi
per la fruizione museale,
sistemi immersivi per l'ascolto museale
e di documentari sonori tridimensionali.
E l'impegno ambientalistico ovviamente,
quello che permette di comunicare
quello che sta accadendo
attraverso un progetto interdisciplinare.
Dunque questo progetto si confronta,
ovviamente, con molte difficoltà:
dal portare tutte queste
tecnologie che vedete
- nell'ultimo viaggio abbiamo fatto
registrazioni di 24 ore
con 38 canali aperti,
quindi 38 tracce, 38 microfoni
che vengono registrati contemporaneamente.
Per dirvi la mole dei dati, [è]
un terabyte e mezzo di dati
portati a casa in tre
settimane, sostanzialmente.
E la difficoltà di far funzionare
tutte queste tecnologie a batterie,
nei luoghi dove l'energia elettrica
si raggiunge raramente.
E di doverle montare e installare
in luoghi ovviamente non canonici,
perché andiamo spesso
in alto, per vari motivi.
Fino a quelle della vita
quotidiana, ovviamente,
prima di tutte l'umidità,
che arriva spesso al 95,
a soglie vicino al 100%,
e grande nemica delle tecnologie.
In questo caso vedete
- questa è una foto del 2008,
eravamo in Repubblica Centrafricana.
Qui il sistema è stato messo
in modo automatico
perché non si poteva stare
in foresta, durante la notte,
per il pericolo dell'attacco di elefanti
che oggi vengono cacciati,
come sappiamo, e quindi attaccano l'uomo.
Ascoltiamo un piccolo frammento
con due specie di scimmie
e una di elefanti:
lo spettro del suono grave.
(Suoni ambientali)
Voglio raccontarvi un ultimo episodio.
Ci trovavamo in Amazzonia,
in questa foto che vediamo,
nel febbraio 2016,
ed eravamo a diverse ore
di canoa e poi di cammino
per raggiungere un'area molto specifica
della foresta primaria, indisturbata,
e ho deciso di rimanere solo quella notte,
a controllare le attrezzature
proprio per impattare il meno possibile
in questo habitat di questa registrazione
di 24 ore che dovevamo fare.
Bene, quando è arrivata la notte,
buio quasi assoluto
nel letto della foresta,
ho avuto paura, ho avuto davvero paura.
E dopo ore di, diciamo,
lotta con me stesso
per riuscire ad uscire fuori
da questa impellenza di andarmene
in un ambiente, ovviamente,
anche quasi completamente
sconosciuto alla scienza,
e in cui mi sentivo un estraneo,
è stato proprio l'ascolto
a riconnettermi e a calmarmi, diciamo,
ho ascoltato come non avevo
mai ascoltato prima,
ho sentito il flusso degli eventi,
ho ascoltato il principio
che teneva insieme le parti
di questo sistema straordinario,
che stava vivendo intorno a me.
Ed è stato proprio appunto
l'ascolto profondo
a farmi in qualche modo riconnettere
e a farmi passare la paura.
Ascoltiamo un piccolo estratto
di questa registrazione.
(Suoni ambientali)
Negli anni, da compositore
che creava la musica,
sono diventato colui
che la cerca in natura,
che la conserva e che
eventualmente la ripropone.
Non è stato facile
rinunciare alla creatività,
propria di quello che fa un musicista.
Ma ho progettato, in questi anni,
degli spazi immersivi per la fruizione
dove è possibile ascoltare
in perifonia sferica,
quindi con una definizione mai tentata,
ascoltare questi paesaggi
sonori primordiali
come fossimo in una macchina del tempo
o in una strana sala da concerto
- o in un tempio, se preferiamo.
E se estendiamo ora questa visione
alla generazione dei nostri nipoti,
oppure dei loro figli,
le registrazioni di cui stiamo parlando
saranno l'unico modo di fare esperienza
di quanto straordinaria e complessa
era la biofonia del mondo naturale.
Vi voglio lasciare con una domanda,
che mi faccio spesso:
questi luoghi, questi spazi,
questi teatri ecoacustici
potrebbero davvero diventare un mezzo
per la riconnessione al mondo naturale,
al servizio del cambio di paradigma
che l'umanità dovrà fare
obbligatoriamente, nei prossimi decenni?
Grazie.
(Applausi)